hi there
here i am day two in athens
uh behind me is the cathedral of athens
behind me over there is our hotel
uh yesterday we were my wife and i were
on the acropolis it was a beautiful day
a tremendous sense of of history you
know 2 500 years ago
essentially the foundations of
of european culture of of much of modern
uh
political science science philosophy all
took place here
but today i'm going to talk about
because someone asked for it you know my
take on the importance of language
for uh our career for our professional
opportunity
so
first of all i'll talk about my own
experience and then i'll have some
general observations remember again if
you enjoy these videos about language
learning please subscribe to my channel
so
in my own case the first language that i
sort of became fluent in was french
and that has helped me tremendously
initially because i then went to france
studied in france for three years took
the canadian
foreign service exam in french
as an anglophone and that greatly
improved my chances of being accepted in
my opinion
so that was so i had an increased
opportunity because of learning french
i was then sent to hong kong to learn
mandarin chinese so i used that
working for the canadian government in
china
i then ended up in japan
where i learned japanese entirely on my
own no teacher no school
and as a result of speaking japanese i
was able to have dealings with
japanese business people who didn't
speak english which was therefore a more
call it downstream level from the big
trading companies where there were
people who spoke english
as a result of that a major canadian
exporting company
hired me to set up an office for them in
japan so obviously my knowledge of
japanese gave me contacts
knowledge of the market i was able to
read the japanese trade newspapers gain
additional information
and eventually it brought me a job
so that helped obviously
uh
i then became interested in learning
languages when i had the opportunity i
learned german i worked on my spanish
and so forth
and i must say in swedish that these
languages have all helped me i wouldn't
say they were necessary but they helped
and so the main thing i believe with
learning languages is
two things really one it increases your
opportunities and i think in life most
of what happens to us
good stuff is often a matter of luck
and so
the broader your range of opportunities
the greater the likelihood that some
good things will happen to you and i
think that's the biggest benefit of
learning languages you just increase the
range of things that might come your way
um
a lot of people are successful who only
speak one language so it's not a
condition
the other thing i think is that as you
learn languages
you become more confident you can deal
in more situations regardless of what
happens you'll be able to communicate
you learn about
different ways of seeing the world
different ways people
live different cultures and i think that
gives you a bigger
breadth a greater sense of confidence i
think all of these things help you in
your career
so it's not like a slam dunk you speak
two three languages therefore you'll get
a better job i believe the economist did
a study that showed that speaking
german added two percent to your income
and speaking french at at one and a half
percent or spanish added two and a half
percent so i'm sure they're all there
are all these studies
but it all it depends on what happens to
you as an individual
i can tell you that
it broadens you
just as for example in the in the last
10 years here that i've been learning
languages that have nothing to do with
my professional opportunities russian
ukrainian other slavic languages
you know korean now um
greek which i'm loving by the way to
discover you know the sort of cradle of
european culture and so forth it just
adds so much and as it makes you a more
complete human being i think that
inevitably will help you professionally
so to summarize
first of all it it it learning more
languages is going to bring more
opportunities your way potentially some
very good ones and second of all i think
as it broadens you it makes you
in a way more complete more confident
and i think that will also help you
professionally so there you have it my
take on how
learning languages can affect you
professionally
thank you for listening bye for now
[Music]
you